Florida Governor Ron DeSantis still has
not even announced that he is joining
the Republican presidential primary and
his candidacy continues to collapse well
hold on if it hasn't started how is it
collapsing the answer is recent polling
you have to see this it it's actually I
don't know that we've ever seen anything
like this the green line on your screen
pointing down is Ron desantis's polling
and I'll give you the numbers if you're
just listening today the purple line
near the top is Donald Trump's which
continues to climb something happened
right around March 28 29th 30th that has
sent Donald Trump's Republican polling
up and Ron desantis's Republican polling
down and this just so happens to have
been the moment where we learned Donald
Trump would be indicted and arrested yes
I continue to believe that the arrested
indictment of trump does nothing for him
if he makes it to the general election
in November of 2024. but it is
undeniably clear that it is doing
something for him in the Republican
primary Ron DeSantis now down barely to
20 percent on average in recent polling
he had reached as high as 32-33 and
Donald Trump continues to climb now
holding 55 of the Republican primary
ballot uh understanding also that a
bunch of the support is among people who
aren't even running at this point in
time Mike Pence has nearly six percent
but he's not running at least not right
now Tim Scott has two percent has not
yet announced the candidacy Larry Elder
has a one point Chris Christie has one
point Christy may run Hutchinson just
shy of one point uh and sununu seven
tenths of a point so what does this mean
well this means that unless Ron DeSantis
can take support from people currently
supporting the failed former president
Donald Trump he has has no path to the
nomination even if Ron DeSantis Scoops
up every bit of the non-trump vote that
only gets him to 45 percent of the
Republican primary ballot not enough to
win that nomination so the question then
becomes
how can DeSantis take voters that are
already supporting Donald Trump and the
answer may be he can't that it's really
up to Trump to mess this thing up for
himself that's one perspective the ways
that it could get messed up for Trump
for lack of a better term
could include more arrests and
indictments that definitively take him
off of the campaign Trail
some kind of misstep but I mean listen
he's been found liable of sexually
assaulting and defaming a woman and his
support just keeps climbing among
Republican voters so I actually don't
know what there is that DeSantis could
do what I can tell you won't help
DeSantis is the wishy-washy approach
that he has taken where he'll sort of
criticize the failed former president
Trump but he really stands for nothing
and he won't seriously do it this is
just one example we looked at this
earlier this week and of course I
apologize to those who have seen this
here is DeSantis asked do you
acknowledge Trump really did lose in
November of 2020 do you acknowledge that
the voter fraud that Trump claims took
place didn't actually take place and
DeSantis standing for nothing take a
listen to this
GOP needs to reject a culture of losing
do you acknowledge that Trump lost and
there wasn't all this raw that he talked
about right well I look at the last
however many election Cycles 2018 we
lost the house true we lost the Senate
2020 Biden becomes president or no
excuse me we lost the senate in 2020
Biden becomes president and has done a
huge amount of damage very unpopular in
2022 and we are supposed to have this
big red wave in other things like
Florida and Iowa I didn't see a red wave
across this country and so I think the
party has developed a culture of losing
I think that there's not accountability
and I think in Florida we really showed
what it takes uh okay I won't play the
whole thing and torture you all with Ron
DeSantis
um this is not inspiring confidence that
is not going to bring over the Trump
people who want to hear him say Trump
did win and this is not going to bring
over the non-trump people who might want
to hear him say listen we lost I wish we
would have won but he lost and I'm
running so that we can actually win it's
not going to convince anyone also an
unforced error for Ron DeSantis is he
keeps going with this anti-woke stuff
which might play okay among Florida
Republicans but when you pull the
country the country is not anti-woke in
the way that Ron DeSantis is acting as
they are here is uh DeSantis yesterday
talking about a Banning gender studies
what this Bill is saying is you know
some of these Niche subjects like
critical the word is Niche sir Niche
this Theory other types of D Niche E.I
infused courses and Majors Florida's
getting out of that game if you want to
do things like uh gender ideology go to
Berkeley go to some of these other
places that's fine
it's fine
yeah and by the way I understand that
both both Niche and Niche are acceptable
pronunciations in 2023 for that word uh
that we people have the country has been
pulled okay and it's not at all evident
that just because Junkin won in Virginia
on this uh you know anti-anti woke
campaign platform uh and because
DeSantis did well in Florida it is not
at all clear that that is going to win
you a presidential election or even a
Republican primary nationally because
for the most part the country by roughly
a 60 40 margin is on the woke side of
things so to get back to our question
you look at the numbers you see the
DeSantis collapse what can turn it
around
DeSantis May believe
that's simply announcing a run is going
to turn this around
he may be right that announcing that he
is running might push him from 20 to 25
in the Republican primary it might push
him from 20 to 28 maybe even to 30 in
the Republican primary but you don't win
with that and it is not at all clear
that he has a path to denying Trump the
roughly 50 plus percent that he needs so
things not going well for Ron DeSantis
things going very well for Donald Trump
in the Republican primary Rumor Has It
DeSantis if he is going to announce
maybe doing so in the next seven to ten
days we will watch it I will of course
let you know Elon Musk the owner of
Twitter and the majority owner of Tesla
I mean at this point he's I don't even
really know he didn't create Tesla I
don't know what the right word is for
what we describe as Elon Musk being with
regard to Tesla that guy Elon Musk
delivered a bizarre interview to CNBC
reporter David Faber a guy who I used to
really like and this interview is a
little shaky for Faber but we'll talk
about that Elon Musk was asked what are
some pretty reasonable questions about
listen of course you can believe what
you want to believe about anything but
does it really make sense to be making
these political statements that are
turning off huge swaths of the
population because don't you want
everybody to be buying Tesla don't you
want everybody to be on Twitter isn't
this what you need and Elon Musk taking
the approach of I don't really care if
it costs me any money let's listen uh to
the first clip this is really just weird
and I think it is important for us to
say Elon Musk has said he is autistic
and I think we need to be respectful we
we don't want to just say
the strange things Elon Musk
the the strange things that are coming
out of Elon musk's mouth are merely
because he's autistic I don't think that
that's accurate and I don't think that
makes sense it also is not often
discussed
that he said he's autistic and maybe to
some degree that does impact the way
that he relates to interviewers during
these interviews I don't know uh it's a
question that I guess should be should
be asked David Faber asks Elon Musk
about you know you're tweeting about
George Soros you're getting into
conspiracy stuff even anti-semitic stuff
arguably and Elon Musk says he is
pro-semite or pro-seminite maybe As
Trump might say it Okay let's listen
properly but I mean you know what you
wrote but you basically it reminds me of
Barbados he's like you know calm down
people it's just not like metaphor
he said he wants to erode the very
fabric of civilization and Soros hates
Humanity like when you do something like
that yeah I think that's true that's my
opinion okay but why share it why share
it especially I mean
why share it when people who buy Teslas
may not agree with you advertisers on
Twitter may not agree with you
um why not just say hey I think this you
can tell me we can talk about it over
there you can tell your friends but why
share it widely
I mean I I this is freedom of speech I'm
allowed to say whatever you absolutely
are but I'm trying to understand why you
do because you have to know it's got a
there it puts you in a in the middle of
a the partisan divide in the country it
makes you a lightning rod for criticism
I mean do you like that I you know
people today saying he's an anti-semite
I don't think you are no I'm definitely
I'm like I'm like a pro semi if anything
I I believe that probably is the case
why would you even introduce the idea of
that that would be the case I I mean it
looks we don't want to make this a
George Source interview no well no I
mean but nobody forced him to talk about
George Soros either so this has a little
bit of a ring to like the whole I love
the Jews they're great business people
thing that we once heard from Donald
Trump in front of some Republican Jewish
group so I I don't know I mean it's kind
of kind of a weird thing uh David Faber
who's the interviewer happens to be
Jewish and he says he believes that Elon
Musk is pro Semite which is an
interesting thing to say uh I think that
I am less interested
in the particulars of what Elon Musk
believes versus what he says to get a
rise out of people
than I am about the real questions as to
what impact this all in particular the
Twitter ownership is going to have on
the discourse and dialogue in the United
States musk also doubled down during the
interview about his claim that there was
no evidence that the Allen Texas shooter
was a white supremacist of course the
guy had swastikas tattooed on his body
but Elon Musk I guess defends having
spread that conspiracy theory
but I mean when you when you when you
link to somebody who's talking about the
guy who killed children in a mall in in
Allen Texas
and you say something like it might be a
bad psyop I'm not quite sure what you
meant but
oh in that particular case uh
there was a
a
somehow that that's not not that the the
the the Arts computer people killed but
the it was I think incorrectly ascribed
to be a white supremacist action
um which it seems to have been and the
evidence for that uh was some obscure
Russian website that no one's ever heard
of that had no followers
um and the
the company that came that found this is
bellingcat right and you know what Bella
cat does psyops right
I couldn't really even follow exactly
what it was you were trying to express
there nobody could yeah in part why I
was curious but I'm saying that I
thought the the ascribing a two white
supremacy was bullied okay and and uh
and and that the information for all
right so anyway we've since learned you
know the the shooter had Nazi tattoos
swastikas all over his body so let me
address one other thing related to Elon
Musk people wrote to me after my Lex
Friedman interview and said David why
are you so soft on Elon Musk is it
because you own Tesla stock is it
because you drive a Tesla
um we have addressed this so many times
I I
first of all on the facts I've sold 95
of my Tesla stock and and I've sold it a
while ago now and I said that and even
when I had the stock it did not
influence the things I said about Elon
Musk number two I'm I'm sort of done
with Tesla in fact when my current lease
is up I think we're going to be moving
on to something very different uh but
but all of that being said I think my my
thing with Elon Musk is there are lots
of people falling into the cult of
personality debate with Elon Musk
whether he's this incredible savior or
the greatest right-wing evil in the
world yes he's saying wild dangerous
right-wing things I don't deny that I
think where I kind of stopped short with
Elon Musk is I don't think he knows what
the hell he's talking about and I think
he's basically been captured by the
people he's been hanging around in Texas
you know Greg Abbott and whoever else I
just don't know that it's worth putting
that much stock into the importance of
Elon Musk in this particular way let's
focus more on Twitter policy for example
than the things that Elon Musk says I
find them deplorable there's no doubt
about it I also think he's done an
incredible thing in how he's pushed
forward electric vehicle and Battery
Technology both can be true there's no
secret there's no there's no reason I'm
discussing musk the way I do it's not
because of the fact that I had Tesla
stock for a while or that I have a
little while left on a Tesla lease so
you could you can stop emailing me with
that stuff but a bizarre interview and
investors I Can Only Imagine
not exactly rejoicing after this
extremely strange exchange on CNBC
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
all right remember that the David
packman show depends on your support
through the membership program to do
what we do and produce five shows a week
and five bonus shows a week you can sign
up at joinpakman.com and remember that
Monday Memorial Day we will be doing a
one day membership blowout this is going
to be such a discount that the lawyers
are going to be banging down my door of
course I won't be home because it'll be
Memorial Day which is why I've planned
it this way the lawyers and accountants
won't be able to find me and you'll get
that big discount a sign up for our
membership at davidpackman.com I'm sorry
for our newsletter at davidpackman.com
and then Monday Memorial day you'll get
an email telling yourself telling you
how to Avail yourself of this great
membership discount all right let's look
at uh so the Durham report this much
anticipated Durham report which was
going to blow the roof off of all of the
wrongdoing that was committed against
Donald Trump when he was being
investigated uh total nothing burger and
we're going to look at this through an
interview this is actually real really
interesting Donald Trump was interviewed
by fired Fox News host Dan bongino
yesterday and Trump told 20 30 lies
about the content of the Durham report
this goes bad quick let's take a listen
I'm always excited to welcome back to
the show
a man who hopefully will be the next
president of the United States a good
friend to the show a good friend to me
personally president Donald J Trump Mr
President thanks for joining us right
hello Dan okay so it's off hello Dan
Trump in a bad mood bad mood Trump is
never good during interviews this has
been written about extensively when
Trump has that bad mood he is a
difficult difficult guy so it gets off
to a notably bad start they go right
into the Durham report and the lies
pouring out of Trump's mouth
Mr President we got the report yesterday
everything you said was correct this is
one of those hashtag Donald Trump was
right again moments is it uh sir you you
were framed you were framed they had no
evidence of any of this from there is no
reason to believe Trump was framed star
your thoughts on that
okay so what they were
going to end we were indeed framed and
it really pertained more because they
missed the dates and amazingly uh the
report was it picked up until just after
the election to remember I think it was
BuzzFeed which is now essentially out of
business I understand which is a very
good thing for the uh for the country
it's great when media Outlets go out of
business per Trump this is done sometime
after the campaign it actually affected
if you look at it and it really study it
it really affected 2020 much more
because we went through years of
nonsense with Russia Russia Russia I
didn't even know what they were talking
about people would come up to me sir you
know anything about Russia if you are
not understanding this word salad do not
adjust your television or mobile phone
or computer screen nobody can understand
what he's talking about here and after a
while I'd say what's going on with
Russia it was a frame up and these are
bad people this is Schiff and Clinton
and all these are bad people but it was
much more than the mark Elias you take a
look at what they did and this really
affected 2020 more than it affected
2013. it was meant for 2016 but they
couldn't get it off you know they they
had this fake dossier written by Steel
and who was offered millions in order to
try and get it confirmed did they stick
with it I'm going to go through all of
this with you in a moment couldn't get
it confirmed he couldn't get anybody to
confirm it because it was all fake it
was like you write a fiction book and uh
but this really affected the 2020.
another thing in the 2020 election which
was totally rigged by the way incredibly
how they didn't want to talk about that
then they didn't want to talk correct
but all you have to do is take a look at
the 51 intelligence agency that's
rigging it take a look at truth to vote
these are great Patriots Catherine
Engelbrecht and these are great Patriots
went around for for a year took all of
the tapes out she sold all of these
stuff the ballot by boxes that took
hundreds of thousands of votes stuffing
the ballot boxes that took place and
just you take a look at just Twitter and
the FBI Okay so it goes on and on and on
but let's add a little bit of reality to
this Donald Trump and Dan bongino and
others would have you believe that the
Durham report exposed quite frankly that
the real crime was even investigating
Donald Trump and that Trump is
Vindicated and all these different
things I don't know how many of you have
actually looked at the Durham report the
Durham report in which they put all of
their eggs in that basket for years the
Durham report found no evidence of any
deep State plot against Donald Trump the
way he claims it does not accuse the FBI
or doj of acting out of political bias
it doesn't accuse the FBI or doj of
acting out of malice it doesn't allege
any criminal wrongdoing
by anybody that was involved in the
Mueller probe except for one low-level
lawyer who pled guilty to altering an
email in 2020 of no consequence big
picture to the investigation the report
did say some with some aspects of how
the FBI handled the investigation like
they opened the investigation on a tip
from an Australian Diplomat they relied
on some uncorroborated information they
ignored uh elements of potentially
exculpatory evidence yeah there were
procedural errors that the Durham report
found it is not indicative of any
intentional misconduct political bias a
deep State plot a conspiracy against
Trump a frame up a frame job framing or
any of it and none of that affected the
validity of the outcome of the
investigation this is in the Durham
report and Trump and bongino want you to
pretend it's something different the
report repeated some debunked conspiracy
theories that were pushed by Trump for
example it wrongly claimed the Steele
dossier triggered the investigation that
is not true that dossier didn't even get
to the FBI until September of 2016 that
was month three of the investigation
already so if you actually look at the
Durham report you find that all of the
stuff Trump is saying simply isn't true
let's listen to just a little bit more
of this interview we're skipping ahead a
little bit here I call them discussion
persecutor not prosecutor persecuted
because persecute is worse but Jack
Smith and he continues to go after Trump
with the phony boxes hoax and if you
take a look at Biden Biden's got boxes
all over the place he had no right to
declassify I do and but you just take a
look Jack Smith this is a continuation
of the same hooks it's all the big hooks
they're all friends they're in there
they're embedded and it's really a
question it's rhinos
and it's Democrats radical left
Democrats I love the way you suck your
show with the radical left you fight the
radical level all right so there has
been no wrongdoing by the special
prosecutor that anybody has actually
been able to point to the idea that any
Republican that actually wants to look
into what happened is merely a rhino or
republican in name only is an old tired
grievance from Donald Trump and the
problem is you look at the post if you
look at this on on Truth Central where
Trump posted it people see this drivel
and then they post wow great show great
show Trump was right
etc etc etc they have fallen for it and
bongino is one of the henchmen that
pushes this nonsense on people look at
the Durham report and you'll see Trump
is lying one other Trump interview I
want to look at before we move on from
yesterday and this is really interesting
Trump was interviewed by Rob Schmidt on
Newsmax Rob Schmidt is one of the people
that went after me about a month and a
half ago uh when I pointed out prayer
doesn't prevent mass shootings Rob
Schmidt jumped on the uh the bandwagon
this is just fascinating Trump
claims during this interview that he got
rid of Roe v Wade this this is very
interesting and consequential listen to
this your response to his allegation on
this and I want to ask also do you think
that six weeks is is going too far is
that going to Doom Republicans with the
moderates in this country when it comes
to 2024.
and everybody said that was an
impossible thing to do I put on three
Supreme Court Justices very few people
have had that privilege or honor and
they are terrific people and they happen
to believe that Roe v Wade should not be
there it's been now brought back to the
States and what I've done is I've given
the pro-life people who are wonderful
people and loving people I've given them
the power of negotiation because now
they're able to negotiate something
that's going to be very important
so Trump saying he really got rid of Roe
v Wade by virtue of having appointed the
Supreme Court Justices he appointed I
would agree I actually Trump shockingly
not lying at least metaphorically about
that the midterm voters noticed and they
voted the way they did in part because
of that this should be a democratic
campaign ad paid for by Joe Biden right
I'm Joe Biden and I approve this message
Trump saying I'm the one that got rid of
Roe v Wade if indeed Trump is the
Republican nominee then Trump went back
to the lies including laughably claiming
that the Durham report is the biggest
story in the history of the United
States
this is the biggest story of
maybe in the history of our country at
the time of the century uh look at what
they report on on other people I won't
mention names other people where they're
they're caught cold they're criminals
and they don't even report they refuse
to you know you can't have a scandal if
you don't have publicity to be honest
you cannot have a scandal now of course
I already told you about the truth of
the Durham report it is not exposing the
crime of the century in fact the report
even says we're not aware of any crimes
at all committed by anyone in the
investigation of Donald Trump through
the Mueller investigation that's in the
Mueller report that's in the Durham
report rather and Trump continues to lie
and lie and lie and by the way we still
haven't figured out what Obama gate is
Trump told us Obama gate biggest
political crime of the century I don't
know which century
um and we still don't even know what
Obama gate is and then lastly Trump
Lament that they want to fire the head
of CNN after that big beautiful Town
Hall that Trump did we're doing before
what they do seven eight nine months is
into a birth or a child a life of a
child those are the radical people not
the pro-life people those are the
radical people and I think I explained
it very well the other night on uh on
CNN you know so well that they want to
fire the head of CNN they want to fire
elect he got they had the highest
ratings that they had in many years and
they want to go out and they want to
fire licks so you know you explained
that one the whole world is topsy-turvy
and what I say yeah it's a topsy-turvy
world out there now the truth is
CNN's ratings for the Trump Town Hall
weren't actually that great it was about
3 million which actually is quite good
for CNN in the sense that CNN ratings
are in the toilet and actually this is
insane but Newsmax had higher viewership
than CNN during some prime time hour
late last week or earlier this week
which which is genuinely stunning stuff
I mean it shows you the the lack of
interest in what CNN is offering it's
not really true though that the the CNN
Town Hall ratings were that great what
happened was Trump's behavior on the
town hall was so outrageous
that after the fact
the reality of CNN doing the town hall
is what made news and the disaster of
Caitlyn Collins's attempts to kind of
hold Trump accountable and the lie a
second that Trump told that's what got
attention Trump likes to think oh CNN
Live got a huge ratings boost because of
me the truth is Trump's Behavior was so
deplorable during the town hall that
after the fact anybody who pays
attention to what's going on in the 2024
race certainly commented on it so the
lies just spewing out of Trump's mouth
but he's clearly doing something that's
impressing the Republican primary voters
because he keeps building his lead over
to santis in the primary polls as we
talked about at the top of the show
let's take a quick break all of these
clips I played are going to be on our
Instagram on our YouTube channel on our
Tick Tock check them out there and we'll
be right back
if you value what we do at the David
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show well it
happens every once in a while at the
last minute an interview goes wrong and
I don't mean wrong in the sense that
yesterday's urine injector interview
went wrong I mean like the interview
just doesn't happen because of a problem
so we're going to take a few calls let's
hear from a few people in the audience
rare that we're able to do this on a
Wednesday but let's see what we get okay
why don't we start first with Jay from
Ontario Jay from Ontario Welcome to the
program
hello yes you're on the air
I was just curious with the whole um the
news about Trump and uh whatever the
other guy's name is uh Giuliani rather
selling pardons for two million I wonder
if it's the in the best interest of
Democrats to try to pass a bunch of laws
um not allowing presidents to have so
much power and I know that that could be
a wide range of things but I wanted to
know your thoughts on that if the
Democrats should try to do that well I
mean sure that the problem is that
presidential pardon power is not a
likely thing to be changed and so then
the question becomes what exactly are
you trying to take away as far as Powers
go now here's here's what I will say jay
one of the realities that the Trump
presidency exposed
is that our safeguards and checks and
balances aren't as robust and
impenetrable as maybe the framers of the
Constitution believe them to be and in
the defense of the framers they probably
reasonably never believed someone as
willing to flout all of those checks and
balances As Trump would come to power
now you could say well they should have
foreseen that okay but they didn't so
then the question becomes what exactly
is it that you would want to change I
don't know if you have something in mind
no I don't and I I think that's the big
problem is that yeah the Trump
presidency exposed that there's probably
a lot of things that we do need to worry
about that we never thought that we
would have to absolutely and when it
comes to Pardon you know the crazy thing
as we talked about earlier in the week
it's not explicit it appears not to be
explicitly illegal for the president to
sell pardons except if it counts as a
bribe or as a fraudulent or obstructive
act and you know to be totally honest I
don't think this selling pardons for 2
million thing is going to go very far I
hope to be wrong and I hope to eat my
hat on it even though I don't wear hats
but I actually don't think it's going to
go very far
yeah I I guess I agree
are you calling from Ontario Canada yes
beautiful how is it there
uh no complaints weather's pretty good I
guess that's good all right Jay thank
you for the call yeah thanks for having
me on David take care all right there
goes Jay from Ontario calling in very
strongly let's go to Liam from Austin
Texas Liam are you thrilled to have Elon
Musk in Austin these days or what
I'm sorry David could you repeat that
question please no I was joking whether
you were glad that Elon Musk is in your
neck of the woods
oh uh yeah not particularly you know I'm
coming to Austin yeah I'm in Austin for
college so it's really weird you know
um campus is not the same as the city
where it feels a lot more like San
Francisco right
well what's on your mind today
David uh this is more of a broad
question but it's addressed towards you
specifically so
of many of the political pundits that I
follow
you come across to me as one of the most
eloquent well-spoken articulated and I
just I wanted to ask you I know I think
you majored in Communications if I did
my research right I just want to know
like how did you get to that point
because you know I really want to be a
good public speaker but I feel like I'm
just not you know so a couple different
things first of all uh we you could have
even included a little more praise
really Liam I don't like that you cut it
off so early we could have done with
more of it no I'm kidding no so here's
the thing there's a lot of different
things I I do think that there is some
predisposition to people who are more or
less comfortable talking and I I just
think it's an open question
to the degree to which one can kind of
like learn to be comfortable talking but
I think it's a bunch of different things
first of all I learned English as a
second language
it's a native language in the sense that
I started learning it when I was five
but I do think that the process of
translating what you know in one
language to a new language probably
helps language development to some
degree
I read a ton since I was a kid
and I think reading is probably the best
way to build vocabulary and to
experience different sorts of sentence
structure and this sort of thing I think
that working in sales was hugely helpful
I've told my Circuit City War Stories
you know being 16 and being put in a
position of selling three thousand
dollar laptops to uh you know 45 year
olds bringing their kid to college or
whatever it kind of forces you to either
sink or swim and develop a rapport and
comfort thinking on your feet and that
sort of thing and then I think just by
like doing a show so I don't know that
there's really an answer in there but I
think all of those things you know I've
attended I've been invited to attend
sometimes like Toastmasters as a public
speaking group where people take turns
speaking and stuff like that I I don't
know to what degree stuff like that is
useful but maybe it is but those are a
few things that come to mind
yeah that's that's very helpful now do
you think this is a quick follow-up do
you think that you were kind of always
since you were you can remember
naturally predisposed towards speaking
publicly you're very comfortable with
yourself like that because I've always
felt kind of like an anxious person no I
mean to be honest when I do in-person
stuff it's like you know we get one and
a half million views a day on YouTube
and 30 40 000 podcast downloads a day
and it's just second nature at this
point because I'm so used to it however
if I'm speaking to a room in person of
50 people I still get sort of nervous so
I don't I don't think that goes away and
I've spoken to people who speak to
really large groups in person they all
have said to me if you don't get a
little anxious before that then then
something actually might be wrong that's
actually a good thing that's a normal
thing obviously if it becomes disabling
it's a problem
right well David sir I I greatly have
tears in my eyes I just so much
appreciate your time today well Liam I'm
sorry I made you cry but I do appreciate
the call
all right thank you there is Liam from
Austin let's go next to Jane from
Hollywood Jane from Hollywood welcome to
the program what's on your mind today
hi
the times I'm an organizer in Orange
County California this is where the GOP
comes to fundraise okay yes one of the
hottest uh political spot we have four
congressional districts that are always
up for grabs and they go both ways
um I've tried to contact you a few times
um but like your technology is kind of
complicated I'll be real with you tell
me what you mean by that Jane what's
complicated about it
the waiting room is silent and so I just
got into a different room in Discord
look I'm a little bit older okay okay
I'm 49. I don't get all this stuff and
it's a little bit complicated well James
since you've been trying to get a hold
of me for so long and we are you now did
let's waste no more time and get right
into your question
okay well my name's not Hollywood Jane
my name's Jenna okay that's my screen
name and well I only see what you type
in so that's why I called you that
I got you I got you
I was a team lead for Unite Here Local
11. okay okay I was I was walking in the
field I helped get utos utoto Martinez
elected in LA
I worked on several campaigns
currently they are I I don't know how it
went because I couldn't find the link
yesterday because there was supposed to
be a vote in Anaheim yesterday on a
measure they were walking in Anaheim
to raise the minimum wage for the hotel
and concierge staff in Anaheim
to be 25 an hour right
the people that they walked that watched
that measure that had the persuasive
conversations
were paid twenty dollars an hour
and they were considered temporary
employees and they did not have written
job descriptions they did not have
safety protocols and while I was a team
lead on that campaign I was bit by an
attack dog and I'm now permanently
disabled
and so when we talk about like how are
Democrats going to win 2024 they're not
going to do it through hypocrisy you
know what I'm saying
um
I will never walk the same again
and I was training up these kids to go
into these doors knock on them and have
the conversations necessary to convince
people to
um put measures on the ballot that would
help workers you know what I'm saying
and so when we talk about like how do we
advance
um Democrats in a a situation where
there's fascism against us we can't be
Hypocrites about it we can't constantly
be like we're gonna use temporary
employment loopholes to take exploit
other workers to advance the rights of
the workers who are paying our union
dues
well I agree with you completely it's an
important point and one that's well said
the organizing can't be as problematic
as the labor situation that the
organizers are trying to fix I do I know
nothing about the specifics you've cited
Hollywood Jane but I will look into it
and I really appreciate you calling in
and letting me know about that we will
investigate and we will follow up let's
go next to Felix from Torrance Felix
from Torrance welcome to the David
packman show what's on your mind today
how you doing David I got a question I
got a question please
um I I see more and more of these um GOP
what they've done and what we all know
is they they have tackled and they have
they have taken social media by storm
basically compared to any Democratic
representative do you think this this at
least one Democrat that will start you
know going on Twitter and I know a few
of them do but they they don't do it as
aggressive as the GOP does Felix I don't
know that I know what you're talking
about who who on the right are you
taught you so let's let's see if I can
ask just ask a few questions are you
talking about Twitter specifically right
now
yeah mostly Twitter correct okay because
and the modular greens and and all these
and like even Matt Gates I mean we uh
when we when we see these these um
YouTube channels all they do is show
their Twitter accounts they always shows
what they wrote and what they said right
when do you think that there'll ever be
like a democratic superstar that just
starts I mean AOC is probably as close
as I've seen yeah AOC is good on social
media I mean Felix one of the things
that you're kind of getting to is this
is a structural disadvantage for the
left and it's the following disadvantage
the rights overly simplistic ideas
lend themselves to social media and
short form communication
significantly more than the left's ideas
and think about you know if you're on
the right you can say
taxes are theft it's my money let us
keep it right the left doesn't have an
equivalent because we on the left
believe listen we would all like to pay
less but if we're going to have an
organized and well-functioning Society
we do need to centralize some aspects
through government and the way we do
that is through taxation which one of
those two ideas Felix lends itself
better to Twitter it's obvious it's the
shorter one right
correct so I think that this is
something that has been a challenge for
the left for a very long time I don't
think it's an insurmountable problem I
think we on the left need to be better
at that sort of pithy short form
communication but I don't think you're
wrong I do think for now the right
certainly is it's it's a near Monopoly
in some of these formats
thank you very much Dave my pleasure
yeah take care all right Felix from
Torrance of great to hear from you uh
let's take a quick break and the show
will continue right after this
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
at this point it should be abundantly
clear to anybody paying even the
slightest bit of attention to the U.S
Mexico border that the border is not
open the border is it's just not open
there's there's no nothing you can point
to there's no statistic there's no
policy you can point to to prove the
case that the border is open under Joe
Biden and so what did former Republican
governor of Alaska former Republican
vice presidential candidate former
Congressional candidate failed by the
way Sarah Palin say when she went on
Newsmax she said the border is open
we're going to check this out this is
another one of these examples of Sarah
Palin in her echoey room visibly
struggling to use language to
communicate anything of meaning
uh in this particular case speaking to
newsmax's Eric bowling about the topic
of immigration and this is an important
issue because the lies that the right is
telling about immigration are uh uh
sticking with some voters let's listen
then we'll discuss a country that puts
the needs and priorities of Invaders
over those who those for it well that
sounds to me like Joe Biden's America
New York is booting homeless veterans
removing them from New York hotels in
order to put illegal migrants into those
hotels and why because these Sanctuary
cities can't handle what they decided to
take on let's bring in former Alaska
Governor Sarah Palin to weigh in
Governor you know an expert on
immigration let's bring in Sarah Palin
this they asked for it they begged for
it we give it to them and they want to
push back now and they're going to move
out veterans who are having a tough time
in favor of
illegal aliens coming in your thoughts
right I mean the whole open borders
issue is bad enough and I sit on the
cake now though is that our veterans
again are being kicked to the curb okay
we're going to go back to it but let's
pause it there the open border thing is
bad enough
can anyone tell me in what way the
border is open and I really want to know
I'm I'm I looked and I said okay let's
look at all changes at the border from
Trump to Biden and I can't find any way
in which that border is open the Biden
Administration has repeatedly said the
border is closed just like Trump did
they have said people should not attempt
to cross illegally just like Trump did
the administration sent troops to the
Border
increased surveillance increased
technology at the border worked with
Mexico to deter migration to the United
States and importantly since title 42
expired the number of people encountered
trying to cross has decreased despite
the fear-mongering by Republicans I was
unable to find a single way in which the
border is open it is true that the Biden
Administration is respecting the process
when people come to the border and ask
for Asylum that is the law that is the
law and it is not a change in policy
it's possible that the Trump
Administration was ignoring the law
but I can't find any way in which the
border is open so if somebody knows
please tell me let's continue here with
Sarah Palin literally as illegal aliens
are being given precedence over this now
there are two issues one is the the
veterans issue and uh it just makes me
sick to my stomach and it makes me sick
to know that our leaders in government
are not giving our vets their due we're
we're not providing them uh the benefits
the promises and and that affects you
know every aspect of most every
Veteran's life this is particularly
disgusting because this is the same
Sarah Palin who in 2008 when she was
running alongside the late Senator John
McCain to be president of for him to be
president and for her to be Vice
President of the United States
she defended the bush decision to go
into Iraq which of course led to
thousands of American troop deaths and
subsequently tens of thousands hundreds
of thousands of injuries and
psychological trauma which then these
very same Republicans were not
interested in properly funding the VA
and benefits for veterans and now she
has the audacity to say oh Biden doesn't
care about veterans oh okay but also
though
in skull definition of treason and if
it's if this isn't treason when you
consider what our leaders are doing in
their aiding and abetting illegal aliens
and they're they're putting our safety
the security of our nation ultimately
our sovereignty at risk we are being
destroyed by the left's open borders
policies all right that I think we've
probably had enough
find me some way in which the border is
open and I will report it tomorrow if
anybody can let me know all right we now
have uh our latest tears in my eyes
story
from Infowars conspiracy theorist Alex
Jones and I want to play a couple of
different things for you one this is
very short but it's just to set the
stage of where Alex Jones currently is
in his sort of public discourse and
dialogue Alex Jones said yesterday that
Kerry lake is really the governor of
Arizona now this is not something that
there is debate you know when I was on
with Lex Friedman a couple weeks ago he
said this thing about how you know isn't
everything sort of an opinion at this
point and I said no it's really not it
is not up for debate whether Kerry lake
is the governor of Arizona a Katie Hobbs
received more votes in November of 2022
in that race
Katie Hobbs was inaugurated as the
governor of Arizona and Katie Hobbs is
the governor of Arizona it's not a
matter of opinion but listen to Alex
Jones you can always trust him to tell
you the truth right we have to continue
to expose what's happened we have to get
Integrity in elections there's total
fraud Arizona's the perfect example
Carrie likes an incredible champion of
Freedom there she's obviously really the
governor the person that ran the
election I believe stole the election
Trump
she's obviously really the governor
there is no way in which Kerry lake is
really the governor and what I think is
really important about these sorts of
Clips is when people write to me and
they say you know Alex Jones was right
about this Alex Jones was right about
that he's the only one you can really
trust
these exact sorts of declarations they
say them so confidently with the total
sometimes it's it's arrogance and
sometimes it's condescension Kerry lake
is obviously really the governor how do
you not know that you there is no
way in which Carrie lake is the governor
now let's move on to the tears in my
eyes story Alex Jones now says when he
goes to Liberal areas in Austin Texas
which he admits it's where the good
restaurants are and listen that's true
that's true the good restaurants in
Austin are absolutely in the liberal
areas uh he says everybody comes up to
him now and says we were wrong you were
right about everything this is sort of
like they came up to me with tears in
their eyes and said sir you've been
treated so unfairly here's Alex Jones
version of that story with the pain of
being prom it not having privacy you
actually get a real gauge I go to the
most liberal areas of Austin now that I
avoided for years has some of the best
restaurants
without even security now wow literally
I go in a restaurant and almost everyone
comes over and says we're sorry we were
wrong we know the government's evil we
know the country's been hijacked I just
took my wife out to dinner with some
friends last Thursday ever almost there
by the in the restaurant came over an
Italian restaurant black white hispanic
old young then I walked to the parking
garage ran to three groups of people and
black white and Hispanic every group
said we love you we're sorry they all
shed it you should think you were bad so
what that shows me is in the most
leftist areas they're even converting
and there is a real Global Awakening
there is a Great Awakening happening as
the counter the great race what's really
funny is you can't find evidence of this
anywhere like think for a second what it
would mean if all of a sudden the
entirety of liberal Progressive woke
Austin Texas was so overcome with the
undeniable truth of the things Alex
Jones has been saying that they now go
up to him and say you've converted me we
were wrong in fact think think about
what Alex Jones wants you to believe
before he needed Security in Liberal
areas because people would come up to
him and I guess threaten him or maybe
accost him or you know whatever
now the progressive left has become so
overcome and enamored with Alex Jones
for telling the truth about the evil
government that he no longer needs
security the liberals who used to pose a
physical threat to him requiring him to
have security now they come up and say
you were right about everything does
anyone believe these stories does anyone
believe these stories I certainly don't
if you do then please leave a comment
send an email I want to hear from you we
have a voicemail number that number is
2192 David P yesterday I interviewed
Christopher key who for a long time has
said he drinks and injects urine to for
health and something about the covet
vaccine the interview was completely off
the wall Insanity many of you I don't
know that we've gotten this many emails
and comments and voicemails about any
interview for a very very long time here
is just one such voicemail I received
hey David I was just listening to your
most recent episode with Christopher key
oh my God that guy's a nut ball yeah I
think he drank too much of his own urine
and the urine's gone to his brain sir
and uh this dude's a Christian and and
he's an embarrassing example of one
because I'm a Christian and he just
makes us all look silly along with a
whole bunch of trumpers anyways thanks
for all you do dude all right I want to
say one particular thing about the
Christopher key interview a number of
people wrote to me and said David why
did you have this guy on why did you do
this some people said it wasn't worth my
time others said it was sort of mean
because he's clearly out of his mind or
just incapable of carrying on a
conversation I want people to understand
he demanded to be on because we talked
about him on the show and that seemed
fair and I'll remind you we have covered
covet disinformation for years and the
covet disinformation has come from
Michael Lynn it's come from Trump it's
come from Sherry 10 Penny and we've
covered the coveted this information
that was being spread by Christopher key
he saw our coverage wrote to me and said
have me on so I can tell you why you're
wrong about all the stuff you're saying
it seems as though if I spoke about
someone
and they say I want to defend myself
that I should grant them that
possibility so we didn't go out looking
to interview Christopher key it's
obvious that you know the the wheel
might be spinning but the hamster's Dead
uh
or whatever other analogy or metaphor
you want to use but he has to be on and
I had spoken about him so that's why we
accommodated it okay please understand
that we have a fantastic bonus show for
you today
there is some really sad stuff going on
with Senator Dianne Feinstein which
we're going to discuss and it's not fun
but it's we need to talk about it
Florida has rejected some Holocaust
textbooks for being too woke a Florida
teacher says she's under investigation
for showing the class a Disney movie
that has a gay character in it all of
those stories will be on today's bonus
show you can sign up at joinpakman.com
and get instant access to the bonus show
oh the bonus show where you want to make
money right everybody else that makes
money to fund themselves is bad please
help us make money on the bonus show and
if you've been saying to yourself you
know maybe I'll get myself one of those
memberships someday
once the price is low enough Monday
Memorial Day we're doing a one day
membership special
it's going to be out of this world
be notified of that by getting on my
newsletter at davidpackman.com we'll see
everyone on the bonus show or otherwise
see you tomorrow